they're playing radio city they gotta
switch back i kind of think the new you
made it is you like your fans you want
to be friends with the people that come
and see you well then let me get one of
my resentments out then
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah let's just let me just i love i
love where you were
let me get the negativity out of the way
i did just listen to your episode with
neil brennan i do believe that you two
should start a podcast called sore
winners
talking about how horrible your life is
when everyone else looks up to you oh
okay so let me get the res go ahead
nothing i was going to give you a high
five but you thought i was raising my
head yeah go ahead high five
they're out of sleep right now
we've been broken up a month the uh
so i just have a little thing just clear
it up for me give it to me um so the
other night about schaumburg improv no
we already got that out of the way
that's right
that's what we'll never bring that up
again it's actually it's true yeah we
actually haven't do you know why because
we've resolved that situation okay okay
we have a new situation well there was
no situation i never did anything wrong
but okay well that's your point of view
yeah yeah that's your truth but um so
the other night we were performing
together you realize that let me let me
just can i get out okay i just want to
say that the thing you got mad at me
about at that chamber improv is that i
laughed too loudly at your jokes on
stage that's not what it was
and how dare you you're breaking it back
up i thought we resolved it but if we
want to bring it back up some people i
just want you to know one day you will
go oh that's right when you love too
loud and i i'm on stage and you're
laughing and there's three other
customers standing with you laughing
together
during in a during a show
yeah we were watching your show and
laughing that's what standing up that's
your job wait you do that a lot to other
comics though that's and i'm not arguing
i've never seen bobby laughing another
comic
i have
i have i'm sorry i'm just can i get the
thing out of my way all right thank you
so and i like what you're trying to do
divert but let's get to the thing
so
just
please okay so um the other night you
knew
you knew
i was after you right right right okay
look at you're right right right
so she's about to bring me up
and she goes this next comic
i love
dearly
right yeah and i go
in my heart i'm like here we are
my friend
jeremy yeah the connection's already
there
i'm a big fan i go i did not know that
but you know what she said it out loud
and that's great
yeah and he's at the top of his game i
go ladies and gentlemen brendan schwab
and then
you go he did an album called caligula
and then my my heart just then my heart
started going
right because it's like all coming to
because i know justin likes back there
and i'm freaking out because i'm like
what the [ __ ] was i called what was it
called
what was it called moby dick
and my old self would have let it go and
let you just bring up anthony doesn't
like no but i did not do that but i did
not do that right
my
my instinct took over i was in the
audience and i screamed at the top of my
lungs and packed room right what are you
doing
something like that right and then you
you looked at me
and then you kind of went
you frazzled but let me just ask you
what was that you just forgot who was
next
like i don't understand because i saw
you backstage you knew you saw the
lineup yep so i don't know what the
confusion was yep so i haven't been to
the comedy store in a while i've been
touring it used to be very like you go
on summit you'd be like and they just
yell it it was just always chaos so
so we were on a lineup it was
i think me
you
there was a popping on the side anthony
yeah i think that's what it was but
exactly what it was but here's the thing
i did not exactly what it was i did not
look at the lineup i'm dumb and i should
have and i don't know what i don't know
what i got there and then bobby was like
oh i'm sorry paulie was like you're
gonna bring me up as a special guest and
i was like oh and i was like okay and
then i was backstage i was talking to
anthony and i i just didn't like so let
me get this right and then i went on
stage and then i went oh [ __ ] is polly
the special guest i saw anthony baxter
and then i just i just
well if paulie
just clear this up yeah yeah if paulie
said to you
that i'm the special guest wouldn't you
already in your mind go he would be next
yes
and then i
did you didn't do that
well i didn't see him around like he was
like i'm and then like i just had seen
anthony i mean i'm sorry i just had a
brain fart but but i i've good news and
bad news
it had nothing to do with you
i just i
i forgot i i know i know you i didn't no
no it's i didn't
i didn't even know you were
it's this is between
this is between me and paulie
do you know what i'm saying i
i just made a mistake and
it's interesting because i am sorry and
i'm happy to
uh
apologize
just as long as it wasn't on purpose
it sounds like an honest mistake and
that's why i'm accepting it just as long
as it wasn't a sabotage imagine bobby's
up but i'm going to bring up anthony
like well i stand to gain nothing from
that
anthony's just going to go on and make
fun of me you know what i'm saying like
it's such a worse thing for me for
anthony to come up next yeah and it's
interesting because i'm as as i feel
like we're
i'm learning more about you as an
off-camera friend because i think it
sometimes well do you know what i'm
saying no we've known each other for 20
years i left going oh my god i totally
[ __ ] up bringing someone on you know i
i mean as long as i've been at the
comedy store introdu 15 years i've never
done that yeah in my life you haven't
and uh never in my life yeah and it
turned into what i thought this really
fun live moment it was
we got we we got laughs out of it like
what's what the comedy store is all
about it was like this unpredictable
moment where bobby kind of came up to
the stage and i had [ __ ] up and there
was this but there's a backstory i'll
tell you why
it's online jesus
i
somebody has it online put your
headphones on
you know him he is so brilliant you know
his
specials okay
yeah so i'm going to tell you what
happened all right so i want to let you
know though i am sorry that's a totally
fine i know but it was i just brought it
up as a joke
to talk about but
no one was madder at me than me and i
i'll tell you why i was sloppy and i
should have right before i went out i
should have looked at the lineup
something funny had happened i was
sitting there in the back row right
with a um some patrons you know
and i was talking to this guy and he's
like aren't you performing and i was i
was acting cool
so i was like sitting next to him and i
was just like
yeah i'm next
and it's
people oh he said just
so i walked into a [ __ ] hornet's nest
yeah yeah so i'm sitting next to this
guy and he's with a bunch of croup
they're from new york like and then we
were talking during your set i apologize
and um
okay all right come on
yeah and
he's like well and this is so dumb he
goes
um so you're next but aren't you
supposed to be backstage and i go you
know sometimes like acting like a
[ __ ] idiot i don't know i go
sometimes i like to just do it from here
right he's like oh that's cool man like
you let like you let your gas tank go to
the right right right right and so and
then as you're bringing me up i stood up
and this group was like this group was
like oh there he goes
right and then once you said caligula
right you could see i just felt
i just felt them going you're not next
you're a fool
right and so that's what there was like
a little bit of a background you were
embarrassed yeah a little bit of
embarrassment there but look she she was
embarrassed she had remorse yeah
i was about to say you know i'm just
going to shut my mouth but there was a
time i called a
a latino comic pablo francisco when it
was like introduced to police back in
the belly room one night i'd like smoke
some weed and i was like pablo and i was
like oh my god francis go wrong
so not too far you know and he walks on
stage i was like i'm so sorry you do
have a problem with introductions
because you told one time said about
martin lawrence he's the greatest comic
on planet earth which by the way i said
here's how on the same page i thought we
were yeah in this moment of like what i
thought was just like a fun crazy like
whitney made a mistake now we're just
gonna
be silly and the audience gets to see
this ridiculous like unscripted moment
bobby one time gave me so much [ __ ]
after i said like this you know because
martin sitcom is my favorite show it's
still my favorite he's one of the best
martin was